not trying to be funny but whoever made
this honey you need your grandma card
snatched back you're not a grandma it's
official it's over hi my name is
Jacqueline Dorsey I'm from Virginia
Beach Virginia
hi my name is Cassandra Fleming and I
was born and raised in Harlem my name is
Mimi Sullivan and I am from North New
Jersey hi my name is Sandra Livingston I
am originally from Louisville Kentucky
you know the home of Kentucky Fried
Chicken Colonel Sanders Muhammad Ali and
me with my sweet potato pie my mother
started me making sweet potato pie I was
always in the kitchen with her every
time she was cooking I was right there
beside her I've been baking sweet potato
pies ever since I was about I don't know
20 years old baby I think I was around
25 years old ten years ago I started
making sweet potato pies as a teenager
um when something happened if somebody
was having something because maybe
somebody was having a birthday party or
maybe somebody was having a cookout I
started bringing sweet potato pies and
once I started bringing my sweet potato
pies people started asking me what's
your recipe and I knew I was on to
something but I don't give up the recipe
you have to snatch it from the heart
okay I can look at a pie and I can tell
if a pie tastes good and my pie just
looks good it's got the look I can't
tell you that because if I tell you I
got to kill you
this is a sea salt caramel syrup now
when you think of South and southern you
think of sweet yes this sweet potato pie
is sweet but some people have an extra
sweet tooth and if you do you take just
a Swizzle of this and put it on top of
the pot or if it may be too much you put
it on the plate because you not watch
the food
absolutely I can't wait I'm just
confident that I'd really make a good
pie
and I'm gonna win this I tried Patty's
pie I've tried all kinds of pies so sure
bring them on of course I'm ready to try
all the people sweet potato pie let's
put this thing to rest and Dean mine is
the best this part might be a little
competition cuz you can look at the pie
and tell what the pie is good amount oh
look at this look at this thing here
this is pretty this is beautiful this
one I love the coloring you see that
orangey color there I like that it was
great you know what I'm sorry
it's good so you've got to get the
seasoning right when you're making sweet
potato pie it's enough sugar in here but
it's the seasonings where's the flavor
where's the flavor in this I don't taste
anything I don't taste sugar cinnamon
nutmeg milk nothing nothing at all it's
just bland it doesn't really taste like
sweet potato to me though but it is good
like a a mixture a pump it's like a
pumpkin with a little bit of sweet
potato thrown and that's what it tastes
like to me you sure this is a pumpkin
she might have did some fraudulent stuff
this six-pack patty LaBelle's pop mmm I
really feel like I can take pin the
bills die about that say that right now
scale of 1 to 10 I would give this I
don't give this a seven I'm gonna give
this five for nothing me
[Music]
okay I can already tell you know what
it's like some people make us a real
stingy prize around here look at this
this it's just a little flat piece
[Music]
mm-hmm that's what I'm talking about
this is a sweet potato pie this is a
grandmother still I will taste that
sweetness
I just don't taste the sweetness I don't
taste the sugar I don't taste enough
mate I don't take the cinnamon I don't
taste any of that not bad
flat but you taste pretty good okay
judge a book by its cover
oh wow on a scale of one to ten I'm
gonna taste a little bit more it's plain
I rate this in all honesty I give this a
- I break this one probably about a
seven scale of one to ten I'd give it an
eight I have a try to eat this need a
little ice cream or something that go on
top of it
you know help to pull it on all the way
up
[Music]
for me it's not sweet enough I don't
taste all those sugars and the cinnamons
and nut me I don't taste that nope I
don't know
there's got some interesting little
characteristics kind of popping up in
there but it would be a little better if
it wasn't so dry can't say that I really
love it
I've tasted better
[Music]
smithing is missing something but I'm
not sure exactly what it is but it's
missing something
[Music]
are these people from the South the
south or what Jersey I will give it a
thneed two point five I give it two
point five because at least it's kind of
got a little texture to it but as far as
flavor goes there's too many strange
things dancing around an empire honey to
be a sweet potato pie I'm gonna get this
pie a three the caramel should have been
a part of the pie now just from the look
at this pie this pad looks like my
mother's pie
and it tastes like I don't like my
mother's pie
this looks um interesting
[Music]
know where I come from I was taught if
you have anything good to say you don't
say anything at all
I will say this no sir oh my god this is
not happening
this is not this is a joke right there's
nobody nobody seriously submitted this
no this can't be
yes as day of wrong I would like to
taste some sweet potato I put in my
sweet potato pie the core 43 the core 43
2 cups I put that in there with all my
other tasteful ingredients and it is
delicious delicious it's not sweet
I don't know you can call this a sweet
potato pie
no absolutely not rest in peace
[Music]
sugar maybe too many eggs seasonings
spices
that's this missing the question I love
the crust really boom that is a one this
would be a tip I would give it a one for
effort
you know they did use some kind of
orange colored ingredient that looks
like sweet potatoes we came here what
specific purpose and that was for me to
win the pie challenge I think I won the
pie challenge hands down
nobody spice tastes like my pies so they
are all good and my vibes good - is just
my spices a little bit
[Music]
you